the video you're about to see was
originally posted on the blue collar
coder youtube channel
so after you watch it if you like it be
sure to jump over to that channel which
is linked to in the description above
for more videos just like this one in
this video we're going to take a look at
some common mistakes that people make
when they use react's use effect as well
as use callback
and use memo and those pesky little
dependency arrays
we're gonna come up with a bunch of
rules that you can live by that are
gonna make
your life much much easier but before we
get into that
if you like this video be sure to hit
that like button if you really like the
video
be sure to hit the subscribe button and
subscribe to the channel ring that bell
and you'll be notified anytime a new one
of these videos
comes out we've also got a discord
channel you can jump on
and that's got a great little interview
channel that you can jump on and
have a talk about any kind of interview
questions really cool
check it out and if you like all that be
sure to
buy me a coffee without further ado
let's jump into the office
and get use effect use callback use memo
and those dependency rays
all figured out all right welcome to the
new office and we're going to start
looking at some viewer code here
so this is an interesting little
component and it's got some problems
so the intent of this component is
that we're going to have an array of
numbers and then we're going to fetch
those numbers from a json payload
so let's go take a look at that it's got
123 in it
and then we're going to go and display
those numbers so
let's take a look and see if that
actually works and right now it gives us
back
an empty array and so there's basically
three problems here
the first is that they're using state
in react in an odd way right they're
basically going and setting
the value as opposed to using the value
setter
and then the second is that they're
using fetch
right in the middle of a component
definition which means that every time
this component is going to be rendered
it's actually going to rerun fetch and
then
the third is that there's i think an
assumption here that
this is sequential right we set the
numbers we go and get the fetch
the fetch completes and then we render
it and that's just not the way
that asynchronous code works so
let's go put in a few console logs here
and start seeing if we can
figure out what some of the behavior is
and learn from that
the mechanics of basic state management
in react but also
use effect and dependency arrays and
also use callback
and eventually use memo and just kind of
get a sense
of a solid underpinning of how all this
sort of stuff works so let's start off
with a console log here
we'll say that this is the start of my
component
and then we'll output the state
so that'll tell us what the current
value of state is
and then we'll say that we are starting
to render so let's go and just
copy that one from the top
and finally we'll capture the output
here as a variable
and then return it so you can put a
little console at the bottom there
on the way out and that'll tell us when
we're done
okay let's go over here to our inspector
and we can see yeah okay so we get
a started we get the numbers well in
this case let's go and
make that number zero so we just see the
numbers which
starts off as an empty array and then we
get the render and then we get the
finished
but what's happening here is that fetch
here is asynchronous so the control flow
is like this
it goes here it starts the fetch and
then it
renders and then it goes out and that's
why
it starts with an empty array and you
don't actually get one two three by the
time
this gets done if you don't believe me
let's go take a look here let's go and
make this a function that has a body
in it so
i'm going to output the data coming back
and also that we're finished our request
and clear this out and run it again and
you can see
now the entire component rendering is
finished by the time that we get the
result back from that json fetch right
so
that's why we're not getting one two
three in here if it was sequential
then we'd have something along the lines
of well we could just go and set this
to you know
four five six like that and yeah
okay so we know that we're looking at
the right data
but we're not actually setting it
properly
so i think the first thing we want to
fix is the the setting
so i want to go back to a more
conventional use of use date and that
means to use
break out this array like this and then
do
set numbers in there now this is how you
state works right it gives us back
the current value and that's a a
constant right
you shouldn't never change this and then
it gives you back a setter and what the
setter does
is when you set the new value it
immediately tells react to go out and
re-render
the component so what's our first big
learning here when we get to this
we go make a bunch of rules
rule number one is to always
use the setter for use date
right so we always want to use this we
never want to set that value
directly so let's go and change it out
so now we're
no longer using the zeroth item there
and instead we're going to do set
numbers
and this is quickly going to roll into
our our second problem
that we have which is that we're not
using use effect and we've got fetch
right in there as part of the render
method essentially of this component
so we'll hit save and immediately my
browser is going to have
start having issues you can see down
here it's just continuously running and
running and running and running right
so why is that happening well so what's
happening is
the render starts and then
during that we call that fetch that
fetch then
sets the numbers and that forces a
re-render right so we're getting the
right data
yay yay okay something of a fix
but now we're just continuously calling
that json over and over and over again
in fact it's it's it's
overwhelming my machine the point where
chrome is no longer really working
if i go down here and inspect let's see
if i can even get up the inspector
guess i can but yeah okay so there you
go you're starting to see just just tons
and tons and tons it's basically an
infinite loop
of fetches so how we gonna fix this
well there's really two hooks within
which you should
go and set state in your functional
component
there is use effect and there is use
callback
use effect is you use when
you want to change state based on either
being loaded or unloaded
or if some other piece of state changes
and you want to subsequently set another
piece of state
and then there's use callback which you
use
when you have a user interaction like a
click
and then you want to set state based on
that so in this case because we're
looking for something where we
are going to set state based on being
loaded or unloaded we want to use
use effect so let's go and
bring that in
now use effect takes a function and
within that you
put whatever your state
setting function is so in this case
that's the fetch and eventually it will
go and
set that state now i will we'll just use
that right
like that and now i'll go back in here
and we'll see if we've solved the
problem yeah it's not even bringing up
the inspector at this point so let's try
it again
all right now unfortunately it looks
like we're getting exactly
the same effect again and that's
predictable because use effect in this
case is being run
every single time this component is
rendered
and the reason is that we've provided no
dependency array
so the dependency array is the the
second argument here
and it basically tells react when should
i go
and run this function here and if you
don't provide anything then it gets run
on
every single render which is clearly not
what we want
so that's a common mistake so let's put
that in there
always put a dependency array
on use effect
for sure actually i'll just add that use
callback
and use memo they all have it
at least has to be there now what goes
in it
well a lot of people make another common
error here which is to say
this fetch is setting numbers and
therefore
it depends on numbers and so they put in
numbers in here
and the result is unfortunately exactly
the same thing
so we're on we're trying to improve this
but we're ending up in exactly the same
infinite loop again and again and again
and it's very very frustrating
and the reason that this is happening is
that
regardless of what number is is we're
still going in fetching numbers again so
even if numbers is now
set to something that we like we are
still fetching
so one way to fix this would be to say
okay well if
we start off with a count of zero which
we know would be the initial state
that's the only point at which we should
then fetch
and just drop that in an if statement
like that
and now let's see i'm probably going to
start up another
tab
and yay finally yay this works so
we start rendering our component we have
an
array set to nothing we then render it
we finish in the meantime we've started
that fetch that fetch comes back to the
data
it then re-renders based on that new
data and finally does
the request finish i think what's a
little surprising here is that all of
that rendering happens when you set
to do that set which i think is actually
pretty cool and fast
so another way to do this and i think
it's a cleaner way to do this
is to leave this dependency array blank
and that's because we know that we only
want to make this request
on the initial render of the component
we only want to do this
once so what happens is use effect
basically starts off with this
dependency array being internally
undefined and then it does a comparison
to whatever you provide which is an
empty array
but then the next time around it
compares it to that empty array again
and says well there's no
difference so you get run once and
exactly only once
so i'm still getting a little warning
here
and that's because at this point it's
telling me well you still are looking at
numbers.length
well let's get rid of that
save it and now there you go i think
that's actually the cleanest
version of this code all right so let's
capture that as one more rule
to run use effect
or any of these others only once
use an empty array in addition to that
another good rule is to say
don't depend on data you set
now that's not a hard and fast rule as
you saw with my comparison
numbers.length
yes you can do that but just you got to
be really wary about that and make sure
that you're doing
it the right way okay now there's two
more
hooks that use this dependency array and
it's worth jumping into those and seeing
how they work as well so you can avoid
any common pitfalls with those
as well before we get in there let's go
and remove a bunch of these console logs
kind of clean this up a little bit so we
can have a much more tourist piece of
code
all right looks pretty good so let's
talk about how to go and handle
setting state based on user interaction
so let's go and create
an add one button that goes and adds
another element to this array
and see how we do that
now in videos in the past what i've done
is create
a function right here
and then use like something like set
numbers
give it a new array with the current
numbers
and then maybe the length of the array
plus one
and i'll set that to the on click
handler
let's see all right that works pretty
well
so this in this example this is probably
fine but if you're going to go and build
your own
react hooks or if you're going to go and
send this add one callback down to any
subcomponents that kind of thing then
it's actually really advantageous to use
use callback so let's go bring that in
and use callback works a lot like use
effect
the first parameter is a function and
then the second parameter
is a dependency array so for the moment
we're just going to set that dependency
array
to nothing seem to work with the use
effect i wonder what it's going to do
here so let's do save and then add one
that's kind of interesting so why is
that happening
we started with one two three we did add
one then we got one
so what's happening here is kind of a
combination of javascript
closures and also the fact that this
dependency array is
set to nothing so what happens is the
first time that my component
gets rendered the array is an empty
array
and then we create this add one callback
and it goes in here and it says okay i'm
going to capture
the state of numbers which is an empty
array
and when i do set numbers i'm going to
take that empty array and then
add you know this next one that is the
numbers.length which is zero plus one so
you get that
one that's how you get the array with a
single value of one
so how do we fix this well what we can
do is we can regenerate
the add1 callback anytime numbers is
changed
and the way that we do that is we just
add numbers to that dependency rate now
anytime
numbers takes a new value we will get a
new version
of add one so we'll save that
and now it works because the callback
gets regenerated every time
now that callback has a stored value of
one two three four five six seven eight
and i wanna hit one add one now
it's adding one correctly to that so
that that works
another variant of this is if you don't
want to go and
keep creating new versions of add one
every time numbers changes
you can use a a different variant on how
to do
set numbers so let me get rid of that
for a second
and set numbers in this case can take
one of two different options
it can either take a value like in this
case a new array
or it can take a function and that
function
gets given the current value is expected
to return from that
a new value so we could do
current value or current numbers
and then return
a new array based on current numbers and
so now this
add one is good forever it takes
any current state and mutates it
let's try that out and it works just
fine
so there's two different variations on
for use callback for you and two
different ways to manage that dependency
so the last one i want to look at is use
memo so let's
create a little thing here called uh sum
we're going to sum up all the numbers
and to do that we're going to reduce the
array so
say that number is not reduced and that
takes a function that function takes an
accumulator
and a new value and we're just going to
add the
accumulator and the value and that will
return a new
value for the accumulator and we'll
start the accumulator at zero
and that'll give us our sum so let's go
and
output the sum there
and away you go now just like with use
callback this is actually probably fine
in this case
this is not a particularly expensive
routine
but if you had something that was
expensive
but synchronous you would use use memo
and what use memo allows you to do
is take that expensive
process and say only run that
when this state changes so let's try
this out
so again we're going to wrap this in
hook use memo and we use
an empty dependency array and we'll see
what happens
so now we've got sum at zero okay so why
is that
well again we start off with an initial
state of an empty array
so it comes down here to use memo the
for on the first render
and it says great i'm only going to ever
run this once and i'm going to do this
this reducing thing right now it does it
on an empty array
the sum of an empty array is zero and
away you go so now it's zero and it's
going to be
zero forever so again the way that we
fix this
we say well this one depends on
numbers so we got to put that in there
and this leads us to our final rule
which is
always add all
the state you read from
to the dependency array
let's go see if it works hey
perfect nice all right so there you go
the three dependency based hooks
and also some common mistakes around
them
and also some rules that will help you
avoid those mistakes
in the future well i hope you've learned
a lot about dependency rays
use effect use callback and use memo
and you've gotten some cool rules to
live by but if you've got some rules to
live by i would love
to hear them be sure to put them in the
comments section down below
of course in the meantime from me to you
be happy be healthy
and be safe